Alfonso poor actor como estas en el
puente de mexico que gusto qué piensas
take a personally dad Eskimo Steven
Steven King a Tarantino piensa que tu
trabajo es única razón que bonito also
can't disguise mira la vida inteligente
a que sentir que ellos los otros hasta
las Busan to trakis siempre William
Goffe mahi not well first of all is the
emotional experience of the film you
know I think that we we go through
adversity every single day of our lives
and we go through periods of big
adversity and those adversity are our
adversity you know in la banda super
Apollodorus el momento que la película
salut y con todo y con todo con todas
estas el Libre Sione's and sido a una
vez más and and you sent you a Lepore
mukhin arose from with where the SI que
les like rescues him yes yeah that was
kind of an spanish-speaking interview
this one yeah
no I'd say that I'm very grateful with
the with the Mexican and an Hispanic
crowd and the the the whole spanic gang
that has really been so supportive about
this whole process from the moment in
which the movie was released and now
through all these celebrations so but
thank you so much